Francis and Gano is going to fight Jon
Jones
what what are you what's coming up Mark
that's the wrong article nope that's not
it no Tyson Fury Francis I love this I'm
actually and I think Tyson Fury is the
best heavyweight ever I genuinely think
he's the best heavyweight ever I am
concerned about this because when boxers
boxers use their gloves they're thinking
about doing the four ounce gloves he
said they're doing foreign so yeah so
it's like boxers use their gloves to
block punches and obviously UFC fighters
can't as well but more punchers get more
punches get through when you have these
tiny little gloves that just kind of
wrap around your fist when you're when
you have these kind of bigger mitts
throwing it up here another mint is
coming it's just two big things kind of
hit it's easier to defend and you're
talking about a guy who's been boxing
every day since he was a kid you can't
relearn your defense yeah and he's a
great defensive fighter but my concern
is that those four ounce gives and gone
to a chance because you know who has
learned how to do a defend he's learned
to defend against four ounces four
ounces yeah right yeah that's a great
point so uh it is something where I'm
like I hope that he gets some sparring
in with the light gloves and I hope he
sees oh [__] certain certain punches are
getting through I can't engage the same
way well he had a quote that at the time
was convincing he said something like
yeah I know he punches hard he's the
baddest man on the planet but I've also
been punched by Deontay Wilder and it's
like that's a good point but then I
didn't think about the fact that more
small punches you've been punched with
eight ounce gloves or ten ounce gloves
whatever they fought yeah you have a
bunch with four ounces it's just knuckle
yeah I mean like it's at that point and
with that amount of weight it's like
but it's kind of cool that he took the
fight on those rules so I think it's the
only way it's remotely 100 yeah uh now I
think it's fake you don't think it's
actually confirmed no no I don't think
they're going to really go all out and
try to hurt one another I think there's
a money grab the fact that you have
Tyson referee in the fight is like he's
never wrapped a fight before yeah it's a
long way that is strange but how hard is
it to rough a fight
your whole life don't you know and it's
getting to like whatever get in there
this is the same guy who shoots
somebody's ear off yeah he's gonna
understand the frustration
I mean shout out to Mike man we want him
on the Pod so I won't talk [__] about
them but but uh
you said yeah my name is Mark Gagnon
yeah
that's very true oh my name is yeah no
don't use white people's voices for your
[__] pleasure bro I liked it son this
is Black History Month you better watch
out I do whatever [__] I want this
mother oh [__] so I just gotta let you
talk like a [__] dignified human
being
for no reason dude
okay okay okay okay uh yeah I think I I
listen I'm buying it I hope they both
make [__] boatloads full of money
um I I think it will be a real fight I
think you just get two guys in a room
and a ring fighting I don't especially
if they're competitive I don't think
they're gonna take it easy like that
Tyson fear is the best at what he does
and God is the best at what he does
they're putting him in a ring I can't
see them both being like hey let's take
it easy like they're in their Prime I
think it's gonna be like how Mike and
Roy Jones was where it's just gonna be
like Mike started to go full in but Roy
was just like pop shots move pop shots
fighting somebody again
oh yeah yeah there's a fight coming on I
forget what it is but I saw it but yeah
he's fighting somebody again somebody
said something I was saying apparently
like boxers don't retire because they
can't hit anymore they retire because
they don't want to take hits anymore
these guys haven't retired those guys
had both retired now everybody's coming
back so maybe whatever but like I can
see Roy 20 years out being like I don't
want to get hit no [__] morning
Francis and ganu and Tyson fear I both
see them being like I don't mind getting
hit I want to win
um I hope it happens
I think Tyson wins because it's his it's
his Arena but the reason why in
heavyweight boxing is so compelling is
that anybody can land yeah it doesn't
matter if the other guy's big and the
force behind that punch is crazy yeah so
it's like anybody can land we're gonna
watch because even if there's a ten to
one favorite he if he gets hit the
amount of pressure that is created at
that weight and that skill is putting
him out so it's like people would watch
Deontay Wilder fight Tyson Fury again
yeah even though
but like they would much and again and
again and again because they know it's
one shot yeah that's what I'm surprised
you think Tyson will win because like he
gets clipped yeah he's gets clipped he's
gotten dropped and he got dropped with
10 ounce gloves now you're gonna get
dropped with a four ounce glove that's a
whole different story yeah I don't think
he comes up from that that's interesting
that's interesting that is interesting
now I will say that Francis ingano has
never boxed somebody of Tyson's caliber
that's my only thing I don't think he
didn't start getting into fight Sports
when he was like 20 right yeah now he
did start with boxing I think that was
the actual thing he first started even
back in uh uh I think he's from uh Cote
d'Ivoire Cameroon no Cameroon yeah okay
my people respect
um so he did start boxing there so he
has some pedigree in that and that's
what he believes that he's good at and
clearly the way he knocks people out in
the UFC is like he's striking yeah but
the skill level of time you're talking
about the best heavyweight ever and the
most challenging ever to fight a guy of
that he's six seven
yeah
I think gone is probably six five yeah
but still like he's up there but still
like and gano's not sparring guys or
maybe is he six nine like I don't know
it's [__] massive so Francis is six
four two fifty I think Tyson six nine I
think I think six nine I mean just
massive and skilled like it just doesn't
happen the footwork the hand movement
like the head movement so how people say
Shaq's footwork is crazy for his size
for his size yeah that's what it seems
like serious but it's very impressive
that Francis is taking the fight he's
like yeah I'm gonna get in never boxing
going up against the greatest heavy
whatever love Francis but what other
option did he have so I
surprisingly Francis does have a lot of
options I mean to make this seems like
eight figure payday oh you're talking
about for the most money for big money
yeah for the most money of course but he
does have other options he could sign
with Bellator he could sign with one
Championship he could do other like
private fights against other guys for
whatever reason not private but like the
one-off type of things so he does have
places he could go but to make real
money yeah it's Anthony Joshua Deonte
watt people would pay to see Deontay
Wilder verse Tyson Fury like we're
literally looking at the most
destructive human being alive Francis
inganu against the most destructive
boxers alive and we will pay top dollar
to see any of them yeah he is in a great
situation and this is why the UFC [__]
up I think in my opinion he's gonna make
way more money not being with UFC even
if he loses his fight the one fight he's
gonna make way more money I was thinking
that so now it's just in further
incentivizes all the UFC fighters back
let me get out of this [__] and then
move on it's almost like a developmental
ground at this point it seems like and
go get your big payday like you make you
climb to the top of UFC and then at some
point there's a massive payday waiting
and they're like look we paid you what
we paid you you want to go get a big
payday go fight a boxer go get a figure
somewhere I don't think the UFC's saying
that at all yeah I I guess they're not
saying that but I think that's what it
could become like at a certain point
with UFC if they're not going to pay you
you could be like all right well that's
fine you have to pay me I'm gonna go do
it I think what happens is you'll see it
will have to change their model and but
the UFC does not see themselves as a
[__] developmental grounds no and
look at you don't really believe that to
potentially fight you need the action
that's the lights that's the stardom
yeah yes go make he's 36 Francis make
yours big Payday money right now but if
you want some engine to continue uh you
know exposing you to the world that's
UFC yeah I mean UFC made Francis there's
no question he also did great within the
UFC to make himself but yeah he did it
but the UFC's if if Francis goes and has
success and these other people go and
have success they're gonna have to find
a way where they don't become the
developmental ground the last thing they
want to be is the thing that builds up
guys and then they go make all this
money yeah they want to be part of all
that money like they were with Connor
the the biggest payday that UFC probably
ever made on a fight was the Conor
Mayweather fight because they were the
Promoter on connoissot yeah so it's like
you need that I'm just shocked that they
that they wouldn't just do hey go out
get that money we'll do one fight with
whatever and then you come back to us
yeah matter of fact Francis if he wants
to he can go do that fight if he wins or
loses can come back to UFC and they'll
have to bump it up yeah
you know what I'm saying like but then
UFC looks a little like they look like
they lost because they weren't willing
to give him the money now he'd come back
and ask for more money and then if you
cave it's like you want to know
something crazy though you're right but
you know something crazy
if Francis wins that fight
okay
he is solidified as the baddest man on
the planet yeah yeah okay
um
how can
a fight promotion be the top fight
promotion if they don't have the baddest
man on the planet you have to empty the
book if he goes to any other one
immediately yeah they are legitimized at
least at the same level yeah that bare
minimum whatever heavyweight fights you
got going on in the UFC they ain't the
ones
yeah and that's not even that expensive
to legitimize an entire promotion think
about that like 30 million whatever the
whatever it is it's like you take that
investment from Saudi you take that
investment Saudi is what I was saying
they'll throw ungodly money at anything
and then immediately legitimize that
division is legitimized over UFC
immediately because France has cleaned
out division yeah except for Jones and
Jones still got to beat throw gun yeah
if Cyril gone beats Jones
it's one of those things where it's like
too much it costs you too much to not
pay I don't know there's probably a
better saying for that but like yeah
um it's like you know when like a tech
company has to buy them for sure it's
cheaper to keep her kind of literally
yeah literally yeah it's like it costs
your brand too much it costs product too
much to not have a place on Fifth Avenue
even if it loses that money right but if
they need to be seen like those other
stores you gotta be gonna put that